black desert mobile is an entire MMORPG
with all of the customization combat and
social interaction you get from a
standard MMO only all of it is on your
phone the freaking future is now this is
a fully featured game so if you've
always wanted to get into an MMO but
never had the game system or the time as
cheesy as it is to say this is the game
you've been waiting for if you're
already a black desert online player
who's looking to take their game on the
go they have you covered - pearl abyss
have replicated the giant open-world war
and a number of classes and content
found in black desert online if you're
new here black desert mobile as the
mobile counterpart to black desert
online a hugely popular MMORPG by
developer pearl abyss the game is
gorgeous they developed their own engine
to ensure the effects are as awesome as
they are beautiful the characters are
perfectly detailed in the study
environments keep you immersed in a
massive world and lore you can see for
yourself that the look rivals even some
games on PC and completely wipes the
floor with the graphics on other mobile
games they flex this graphic muscle
during the character creation phase
which is literally the most detailed
I've ever seen the gameplay itself is
ridiculously fun there are all the
quests bosses and battles that you would
come to expect from black desert and
pearl abyss have created a whole new
combat system to make the game feel
great to play on your phone the way you
play a change is depending on which of
the five characters you choose and the
skills that you choose for that
character warriors are agile but heavily
armored close-quarter fighters who can
dodge in and out of combat and change
stances to block frontal damage in PvP
they can handle themselves but lack many
support skills to aid their allies
Valkyries are heavily armored shield
maidens who fight close and specialized
in defense and damage mitigation they
use the Holy Light of Elian to keep
their more frail allies from death and
can knock opponents to the ground
Rangers are good at keeping their
enemies at a distance they're strong
against single targets and thrive on
kiting and avoidance in PvP Rangers can
make use of their stuns and kicks to
keep the enemy locked down until they
die giants are double axe wielding
Berserker psychos who charge into close
quarter combat Indy
massive AOE damage they're definitely
the class for people were impatiently
waiting to kick ass I like which is the
best though there are classic mage who
use the powers of nature to burn
electrocute and freeze their way to
victory they're casting times make them
need to stay behind they're tougher
allies but their damage output more than
makes up for it your character has an
in-game life complete with a camp that
you live in and NPC workers that you
manage you can tame creatures including
mounts that you can ride and you can get
cute pets to help you along the way all
of this can be upgraded with resources
you obtained through mining logging
fishing and foraging for herbs you know
work hard play hard while playing a game
black desert mobile is the full MMO
experience available on your phone and
it's out now so go give it a try while
you're bored and see how fast you wish
you have more downtime thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you in the
black desert
[Music]